en vivo voy a probarlo volver
oigan una super disculpa tuvimos ahí una
falla técnica para que vean que esto se
hace en vivo grabado y que la tecnología
pues a veces también nos juega algunas
malas pasadas
brevemente vamos a retomar la parte de
la participación de adriana lara que muy
amablemente nos estaba hablando de su
experiencia como maestra de ciencias
sociales usando khan academy y el
campeonato entonces adriana cuéntanos
o explícanos si yo soy una maestra que
un maestro o maestro que a partir de hoy
a partir de este youtube live digo
quiero entrar al campeonato ya pasó un
mes pero todavía quedan seis semanas
como podría yo nivelar me en tiempo o
sea no me afecta que yo me incluya fuera
de tiempo no simplemente como docentes
ya tenemos la planeación ya no las están
dando al que simplemente dosificarla a
los tiempos lo bueno de esto es que lo
puedes hacer tanto dentro de tu clase
como fuera es actividades son las
actividades muy muy cortas esto es lo
padre que a los niños les gusta y lo ven
como un reto en mi caso lo están viendo
hasta como un premio fuera de aula y
como parte de después de realizar sus
tareas escolares la dosificación la
pueden hacer ya que khan academy nos
está haciendo las actividades también
realmente muy dosificadas tanto lo que
tiene que hacer el alumno como nosotros
como profesores no las está explicando
de una manera muy detallada
y son cortas entonces no nos afectaría
que ahorita se para inscribir a lo cual
los aliento por favor van a ver el
cambio de sus alumnos y la motivación
que van a tener está perfecto
y cuál consideras adriana que ha sido tu
mayor reto porque recordemos que tú
estás utilizando las actividades de
mentalidad de crecimiento o sea
realmente no estás utilizando tuvo un
contenido académico ni de matemáticas ni
de ciencias ni de inglés siquiera
entonces cuál ha sido tu mayor reto con
tus grupos con tus alumnos en primer
lugar conocer que la mentalidad de
crecimiento o sea desde allí que con la
pequeña explicación que nos dieron y un
vídeo este de ahí evidentes para de
profes y que es que es la mentalidad de
crecimiento para los profes que se
acaban de unir o que dicen bueno y eso
que es yo doy matemáticas que es eso
cuáles son las actividades crecimiento
se hacemos no explicar rápidamente de
esta manera y perdón este la comparación
al igual que los músculos y nos gusta
me gusta ir a hacer ejercicio y
fortalecer para el cerebro es lo mismo
podemos estar fortaleciendo nuestro
cerebro con las diversas actividades de
pinky think que le dicen mis alumnos que
es el que está ahí en en la mentalidad y
estar en constante cambio estos
aprendizajes que es aprender desaprender
y volver a aprender porque porque no
todo es memorización entonces al ver que
ellos ponen en juego estos aprendizajes
que ya tienen en diferentes actividades
ayudan a que estén ampliando su mente la
manera de estudiar la manera de aprender
ok perfectísimo no sé si por ahí
tengamos alguna duda en el chat
vamos a ver cómo puedo ser maestra dicen
por ahí
dark paranormal a qué te refieres con
cómo puede ser maestra
y luego como me puede ayudar a estudiar
aquí para el examen de la universidad
pues depende de la materia
paranormal depende de la materia del
contenido tendrías que seleccionar tu
nivel para que puedas ir tú llevando las
actividades de determinada materia a tu
ritmo
creo que por el momento no tenemos otra
dice yo doy el módulo de formación
empresarial y estoy trabajando
actividades de emprendimiento estas no
son obligatorias sin embargo los
estudiantes están trabajando mucho en
las actividades a perfecto eréndira
entonces si estás utilizando tú también
las actividades de mentalidad de
crecimiento supongo
supongo supongo pero también hay otra
parte que dice emprendimiento me parece
que está como emprendimiento y finanzas
milán wesley y esa parte les ayuda
también muchísimo a los alumnos a
entender todo esto y excelente bueno
vamos a ver si siguen saliendo por ahí
más preguntas tal cual normal ahorita te
pasamos la línea para que puedas entrar
a khan academy te puedes registrar
mientras tanto vamos a seguir con
nuestro segundo invitado el les
baraquiel valdez él es profesor de
informática en el colegio de bachilleres
en sonora el implementa proyectos de
tecnología educativa en su escuela y
además está a cargo del programa de
recurso miento virtual esto es llevar a
los estudiantes que por alguna razón no
acreditaron alguna asignatura de manera
presencial para que la puedan acreditar
de manera virtual entonces la verdad es
que tiene bastante experiencia en este
tema del muchacho y nos va a enriquecer
mucho lo que nos puedas aportar para que
el cómo estás
bien gracias ahora vamos primero gracias
por muchacho no definitivamente y a
todos bienvenidos aquí a esta segunda
retransmisión de verdad que estábamos
aquí todavía pues un poco apenado pero
contentos de seguir aquí con ustedes
básicamente la experiencia que yo traigo
con con camps se gire alrededor de la
autoestima de los estudiantes porque
entramos con khan academy bueno entramos
particularmente por la necesidad de
contar con mayor cantidad de materiales
interactivos para los estudiantes como
la hora comentaba ahorita dentro de mi
escuela nosotros nosotros estamos a
cargo del programa de recurso miento
virtual y este programa pues al ser un
programa totalmente en línea para los
estudiantes pues requiere de materiales
interactivos dinámicos y atractivos para
los estudiantes entonces estamos
trabajando lo que es una serie de
diseños evidentemente esto pues toma su
tiempo y cuando estábamos analizando
todas las opciones que había pues nos
encontramos con acá y tomamos sacan y lo
integramos como una práctica pues
fantástica no exitosa los materiales que
se manejan encarna como comentaba
ahorita es la hora y adriana son
diversos si hay una cierta inclinación
evidente para matemáticas y ciencias
pero en realidad todos los materiales
que están ahí son muy atractivos son
cortos son específicos ayudan a nuestros
estudiantes a resolver dudas en
particular además de las de las debidas
asesorías que nuestros docentes imparten
por supuesto sin embargo cuando
estábamos trabajando yo como can que
sale este tema el campeonato nosotros le
dimos una una plusvalía muy interesante
que era el tema de hacer una cohesión
grupal y elevar la autoestima de
nuestros estudiantes
yo estoy participando con el campeonato
en dos versión en dos vertientes primero
en el programa de recurso miento donde
el campeonato está siendo utilizado para
efectos de que nuestros estudiantes y
lbn la autoestima que tienen en el
programa o sea es decir no por el hecho
de haber acreditado en la modalidad
presencial alguna asignatura pues no
significa que nosotros no podemos no
seguimos creyendo en ellos como
campeones entonces esto ha tenido un
efecto positivo increíble entre nuestros
próximamente ya vamos a empezar a
involucrar a nuestros estudiantes
directamente a las actividades vamos a
comenzar con mentalidad y crecimiento
que es lo que esta mentalidad
conocimiento perdón que lo que está
trabajando adriana pero la intención de
llevarlos mucho más allá en el área de
matemáticas todos los todos los temas
están siendo ya integrados los
materiales de khan están siendo
integrados en ciencias también llevamos
un avance significativo que es lo que me
ha ayudado me ha ayudado definitivamente
los resultados no en la segunda
vertiente que les decía que yo estoy
trabajando estoy trabajando con mis
estudiantes también al mismo tiempo en
un grupo que imparto en este modalidad
presencial como decía él ahora soy
docente informática tengo un grupo por
las tardes y sea un efecto muy
interesante en este inscribí a mi grupo
ya como docente yo doy campeonato
y se les han ido asignando las tareas
comencé al igual que adriana con
mentalidad del conocimiento este pero
recientemente tuve una experiencia muy
padre
el campeonato está midiendo en niveles y
conforme los estudiantes van realizando
cada cada uno tres asignaturas las
tareas pues va subiendo y va subiendo el
nivel del grupo como equipo
recientemente hicimos la proyección en
el cañón como leonor nos comentaba este
pusimos el tablero y pues a revisar led
y le di click al revisar el avance y
vimos cómo avanzaban y avanzaban y
avanzaban de nivel de repente llegamos a
un nivel en el que mis estudiantes se
dan cuenta que se quedan como la mitad
del 5 no lograron llegar hasta el tope
del 5 y entonces sea un efecto muy padre
de no profe por favor vamos a utilizar
la clase vamos a terminar acá en el
equipo no ha terminado y se empezaron a
organizar entre ellos mismos para
terminar con las actividades para volver
a revisar el panel de avances justo
antes de terminar la clase le damos clic
nuevamente a revisar el panel de avances
y puedo sorpresa terminan 5 terminan 6 y
se quedaban a la mitad del 7 cuando la
meta era llegar hasta el nivel 6
originalmente no ahorita ya mis
estudiantes ya se acabaron todo lo que
es me salía el conocimiento y ahora me
están pidiendo muchas más actividades
pero para poder seguir subiendo el nivel
un factor yo importante que yo creo que
no hay que perder de vista en el tema
es esta cuestión que da el grupo en el
que logran algo todos juntos si bien no
es una competencia por ser el primero en
llegar hasta el nivel más alto o si bien
no están compitiendo directamente contra
otros equipos el saberse en cada uno
parte de una maquinita muy bien
engranada que está teniendo objetivos
que se están planteando y que están
celebrando porque cada vez que ustedes
pongan a revisar el panel de control van
a ver cómo se sale todo de la balanza
van a empezar a todos a gritar aplaudir
emocionados por algo que a lo mejor
ustedes digan que no era muy importante
el principio debo decirlo yo persona
personalmente creía que con con la
integración grupal que tenía en este
grupo de la tarde pues no iba a ser tan
duro el efecto no como había otros
vídeos que me ha compartido adriano que
pueden encontrar a ustedes en la página
de canal pero no sorpresa que el efecto
es el mismo
el tema del estudiante de media superior
y educación superior yo creo que es un
tema en el que si algo sale generalmente
de la mesa es la autoestima del
estudiante como ya estamos hablando de
jóvenes adultos o de adultos o de alguna
manera como docentes pues nos
concentramos en lo que van a lograr
ellos y las habilidades que necesitan
para desenvolverse en el área laboral es
decir ya de nuestro de nuestra escuela
van a salir incluso desde la prepa van a
salir a la fuerza laboral y nos interesa
más en conocimiento y las herramientas
que puedan necesitar para valerse por sí
mismos cuando le das una pequeña
atención a la autoestima del estudiante
cuando es una pequeña atención a esa
celebración interna que puede tener los
efectos son fantásticos de veras si son
estudios y son docentes de preparatoria
o de universidad les recomiendo
ampliamente que inicie en el campeonato
documenta ahorita adriana el hecho de
que estemos listas a seis semanas de
concluir no afecta en lo más mínimo el
efecto va a ser el mismo es trabajar
desde la semana 1 semana 2 los informes
de los diversos contenidos por otro lado
estoy seguro que les van a hallar un
implemento para sus estudiantes en mi
caso particular soy docente informática
hay algunos materiales hay dirigidos al
área informática pero derivado de que
tuvieron contacto con khan academy los
estudiantes entonces empezaron a revisar
los materiales en matemáticas empezaron
a revisar los materiales de ciencias y
empezaron a encontrar respuestas a dudas
que tenían en otras clases y se siente
muy padre que lleguen y platiquen de oye
profe vista este vídeo y este esto no
entendía cómo se cómo era lenguaje
teórico por ahora ya me queda claro no
es mi clase darles el lenguaje
geográfico pero se siente muy padre que
se haya sido tú quien lo puso en
contacto con una herramienta que les va
a ser muy útil este perdón que te
interrumpa al que les está padrísimo
porque muchas veces pensamos que a lo
mejor chicos más pequeños a lo mejor el
secundario en primaria como que tienen
de repente la curiosidad por hay una
cosa me llevó a la otra y la comparto
con con el profe y que a lo mejor los
chavos de prepa pueden ser como más
apáticos o más lejanos
aquí nos damos cuenta de que no sea
realmente ellos y empiezan a utilizar la
herramienta y a darse cuenta de que a
través del uso de la tecnología pueden
resolver algún tema que les quedara
pendiente de este ciclo de este semestre
o que traigan arrastrando desde atrás
como que los motiva a seguir aprendiendo
y se dan cuenta de que pueden resolver
ese problema ahora o sea no se tienen
porqué quedar con lagunas no baraquiel
antes de hecho algo que es muy
importante y qué bueno que mencionas el
tema este apatía la ahora si en efecto
tendemos a clasificar mis compañeros de
media superior que veo que están
haciendo comentarios y de repente
conalep cobach éste no me dejarán mentir
tendemos a encasillar al joven de media
superior como un joven apático pero la
realidad de las cosas es que está
pasando por una etapa de su vida o por
una etapa de su desarrollo personal en
el que a lo mejor se vuelve un mente
desafiante y nosotros estamos
acostumbrados a hacerla de alguna manera
la autoridad no el docente siempre ha
sido la autoridad del aula y te
enfrentas a estos estudiantes y tiendes
a alejarte de ellos de alguna manera o
sea en realidad entre muchos de mis
compañeros es unas estrategias más
comunes de alguna manera mantener una
cierta distancia no porque si no se te
echan encima como como mencioné
coloquial verdad
de las problemas entonces mejor ni
siquiera te pongo atención el mismo
problema no y fíjate que sea un efecto
muy curioso porque entre más tiempo las
clases en medio superior ahora sí que tu
corazón sabe endureciendo se acostumbra
hay clases pues entonces de repente nos
entras a un kinder y lloras
por el amor que se que se ve en las
aulas etcétera pero el asunto es hay
muchas maneras de llegar a la habilidad
socio emocional del estudiantes hay
muchas maneras de llegar a ese factor
del ser humano integral que también es
responsabilidad nosotros y creo yo que
el campeonato yo por medio de cannes una
muy buena estrategia
se los digo por experiencia el hay otro
hay otro punto importante en media
superior siempre se trabaja mejor cuando
el grupo está contento cuando cuando los
estudiantes se apoyan entre ellos cuando
los estudiantes saben trabajar juntos
cuando los estudiantes formas equipos y
no dicen nada con el profe quiero'
cambio se va a notar que en la dinámica
grupal es mucho mejor te permite avanzar
más rápido en los diferentes temas te
permite ser hacer más dinámicas en el
grupo y el campeonato logra eso porque
no importa si le cae bien o le cae mal
el compañerito la compañerita en
realidad necesita que ese compañero o
compañera haga su parte porque entonces
lo que tú hiciste no pueden cargar con
todo el grupo y esto es algo eso es algo
muy muy muy interesante habitualmente
cuando trabajamos proyectos en equipo
sucede que a lo mejor hay un estudiante
o dos que tienden a cargar todo el
proyecto con tal de salir bien y en el
campeonato no se puede pueden agarrar
ellos y determinar todo y terminar antes
en antes de que terminas darle click si
quieres destinar pero la realidad las
cosas de que sus puntajes no van a ser
suficientes para que el grupo logre
avanzar
los más adelantados necesitan que el
resto de sus compañeros también avancen
junto con ellos y sea un efecto muy
interesante de qué va el que se entendió
le tiende la mano al que no y lo ayuda a
seguir porque porque les interesa a
todos ganar juntos algo que nosotros nos
está funcionando es explotar ese factor
de competencia en el caso por ejemplo el
programa de recurso miento que les
comentaba iniciamos trabajos de hace
unas semanas y yo les decía el grupo que
logró un avance más más alto me lo llevó
a comer al docente no ese es él es el
premio están todos peleando por una
comida previa nada más es para el
estudiante es también parecido está
claro pero que tan gran distintos grupos
el ahorita mi grupo es de 41 pero los
grupos de reclutamiento no tenemos a
cerca de 3.000 estudiantes en el
programa vamos a tener que hacer muchos
grupitos para poder cabo leyes
evaluar y el tema aquí es que fíjate lo
comentó como broma al tema cuando no es
broma es cierto no lo a la comida para
lo mejor parece algo trivial pues a lo
mejor parece algo como malo guevara
cuarto pero habitualmente nos olvidamos
de premiar al docente o sea generalmente
nos concentramos en premiar al
estudiante en lo cual es perfectamente
válido pero se nos solar el docente
entonces y es y el rol de nosotros como
docentes ahorita en el campeonato es
clave porque la motivación si es cierto
a arrancar y los muchachos pero tenemos
que también nosotros saber dosificar
saber motivarlos a hacer este momento de
vamos a ver y vamos a festejar te obliga
a festejar con ellos por más que uno no
quiera me sucedió por más que trata de
guardar la compostura yo no pude y
también me puse a gritar cuando poner el
nivel 6 porque te pondrá que es uno la
alegría de ellos ya en el tema de grupos
institucionalmente vamos a tratar de
llevar a todos los grupos este por medio
de campeonato y vamos a llegar a una
pequeña premiación interna este sin
embargo lo que se llevan más nuestros
estudiantes es la satisfacción de lo que
lograron
y lo que lograron como equipo es lo más
importante de todo trabajaron en equipo
se cuestionaron con su grupo y selena
adelante eso es algo muy valioso el
programa
perdón en una situación aquí también
algo que mencionaba para quien es no
nada más estás haciendo esto sino la
otra es que puedes hacer aula invertida
lo cual ayuda mucho a los estudiantes y
el uso de la tecnología que lo vean
también que es parte de un aprendizaje
lo pueden llevar al área académica
o sea no es para jugar nada más no es
para entretenerme también puedo aprender
súper valiosa tu aportación adriana
muchísimas gracias no sé si por ahí en
el chat tengamos dudas para barack y él
e
creo que para baraquiel específicamente
no si de ahí por ahí algunas preguntas
haci ali muchas gracias siempre hay
algunas preguntas pero ya le honor y al
y nos están apoyando para resolverlas
entonces nos quedan 20 minutos si
llegase a haber más dudas o más
preguntas tanto para adriana lara como
para baraquiel este las vamos a abordar
hacia el final se acaba de integrar
también con nosotros adriana flores ella
es maestra de matemáticas en conalep en
ciudad de méxico al plantear a aragón sé
que por ahí tenemos profesores de
conalep también ya conectados y bueno
algo interesante de adriana flores es
que ella ha estado usando khan academy
durante tres años e incluso ha dado
capacitación sobre la herramienta en
otros planteles entonces creo que su
experiencia va a ser bastante rica
bienvenida adrián a
el espacio es todo tuyo cuéntanos de tu
experiencia creo que tienes por ahí
cerrado el micro todavía pero cuéntanos
de tu experiencia
no no te escuchamos a drenar allá aire
al área
hola buenas tardes si efectivamente este
yo ya llevo tres años trabajando con la
plataforma de hecho es en conalep es una
herramienta que se trabaja ya esté en la
mayoría de los planteles hace tres años
que tuvimos una la primera reunión de
docentes de matemáticas a nivel nacional
este fue cuando nos presentaron esta
plataforma fue cuando empezamos a
trabajar con ella fue cuando la
conocimos este de hecho no sé si estén
por ahí conectados unos de los
impulsores que éste que nos mostraron
esta página que son docentes de
tamaulipas los que nos enseñaron y nos
mostraron y a partir de ese momento pues
empezamos a trabajar ya durante tres
años esta plataforma que para mí
personalmente ha sido muy
muy es una herramienta muy didáctica
porque los chicos la entienden y se
familiarizan con ella y es atractiva y
divertida al menos ello así ellos así lo
han visto y que a mí me ha servido para
poder nivelar a algunos de los alumnos
que a veces traen otras deficiencias que
nosotros no podemos cubrir en clase éste
a veces pues los tiempos son muy cortos
y no tenemos la oportunidad de ver todo
lo que quisiéramos o de reforzar todos
los temas en los que ellos esté pues no
hay un conocimiento bien asentado y
entonces con el apoyo de la plataforma
hemos podido cubrir estas deficientes en
estas deficiencias en mi plantel
específicamente si tenemos horarios
destinados para trabajar con el uso de
la plataforma porque pues a veces los
laboratorios los utilizan los profesores
de informática o los procesos de
expresión gráfica digital pero si la
academia de matemáticas pidió un espacio
este ya que vimos todos los beneficios
que tenía la plata
para poder trabajar exclusivamente
durante la escuela una hora por lo menos
a la semana con el uso de la plataforma
ahorita que entramos de hecho estuvimos
en el concurso del año pasado y ahorita
no me acuerdo bien cómo se llama que
también lanzó este can academic y en
este que se inicia ahora que es el
campeonato pues desde el inicio
estuvimos al pendiente estamos
trabajando tenemos un grupo que va muy
avanzado que va a llegar prácticamente
ya la copa número 15 es un grupo de
quinto semestre y no y está muy
comprometido hemos festejado también y
como lo decía este mi otro compañero a
veces exactamente gana la emoción y
festeja junto con ellos
cuál ha sido el incentivo para que ellos
trabajen en la plataforma primero algo
que hemos establecido que establecimos
como academia puede darle un peso en su
evaluación a la plataforma entonces ya
lo tomamos con un poquito más de
seriedad ya no es este si es un juego no
es una manera divertida para aprender
pero que también va a tener una
recompensa que es un porcentaje pequeño
en tu evaluación pero que sirve como
motivación para los chicos otra que yo
esté otra aplicación que yo he hecho es
darles pequeños obsequios no a la
persona que mejor trabaja el que más lo
hace al que tiene mejores puntuaciones
pues otorgarle un pequeño obsequio ya vi
que mi compañero decía que una comida y
contra el profesor pero no yo yo han
sido pequeños obsequios una memoria unos
audífonos pero esas pequeñas cosas han
hecho que más alumnos se preocupen en
decir hay ahora vas a ver que yo voy a
ganar yo te voy a ganar yo voy a hacer
más puntos que tú entonces éste
esa es la manera en cómo ellos se van
motivando en que van viendo también
la herramienta si les sirve y que algo
que no sabían o que no tenían bien
reforzado ahora ya lo saben con los
ejercicios continuos que hacen se si han
mejorado este en la materia de
matemáticas yo ahorita estoy en primer
semestre y en quinto semestre son así
como que dos módulos completamente
separados y diferentes porque a lo mejor
los de primero apenas van empezando no
conocían este tipo de herramientas
muchos no saben manejar computadora pero
si traen celulares entonces lo hemos
manejado en computadoras a veces los
laboratorios que nosotros tenemos pues
son pequeños y los grupos son muy
grandes tenemos grupos de 45 50 alumnos
entonces a veces las computadoras no nos
alcanzan pero empiezan a trabajar en
pares o nos empiezan con que yo soy
usuario a telcel y como no soy a telcel
la plataforma es gratuita pues centro
desde mi celular y están en el
laboratorio pero están haciendo uso de
su celular y se meten a la aplicación y
están haciendo las actividades no
entonces vemos que no siempre la
limitante es si no tengo un laboratorio
en donde tengo que trabajar
sino que yo sé que también lo puedo
hacer desde mi celular y entonces estoy
aquí en clase pero estoy trabajando
desde mi celular entonces yo creo que es
la manera en como nosotros les
planteamos a los chicos que también
nosotros qué tan difícil lo veamos
nosotros les decimos no si se puede
haber traído teléfono por extensión mira
puedes entrar de esta manera y entonces
ya se va corriendo y ya todos se
empiezan éste a participar y esta parte
de dar pequeños premios a lo mejor en un
corte de evaluación yo a veces lo he
hecho que les digo el que haya trabajado
o el que haya tenido mayor puntuación le
doy un punto extra y entonces todos
quieren tener ese punto extra entonces
eso es lo que nos ha servido y ha
funcionado y a mí personalmente que
vamos muy muy bien en este campeonato
que ya cumplimos con las metas que eran
establecidas que era llegar a la copa 6
ya la estamos superando y pues espero
que a todos no se les haga difícil creo
que las barreras las ponemos nosotros y
nosotros somos los que tenemos que
eliminar a veces no es de que es que no
me prestan en el aula de cómputo pues
voy a buscar con quién hacer lo
necesario para qué
puedan saben que chicos pueden entrar
desde su casa a 5 10 minutos
asignar actividades sencillas tampoco no
queramos asignar actividades en las
cosas que ellos no saben o todavía no
aprenden a hacerlo como que lo más
sencillo y empezar a reforzar esas
pequeñas cosas que ellos no saben o no
querer nos irá y vas a tener 30
ejercicios y de lo más complejo no yo
creo que actividades sencillas y metas
que se puedan cumplir
excelente fíjate que me parece muy
interesante lo que dices de
no quedarnos como con un pretexto o con
una barrera sino buscar la manera de
sortear la porque precisamente nosotros
como profesores con los alumnos pues les
diríamos eso no o sea si el chavo que
llega y te dicen no maestra pues es que
no pude traer la tarea porque se la
comió mi perro híjole pues pues no lo
pudiste hacer otra vez eso no pude
traerle la tarea porque no había luz
bueno no la podías hacer a mano o sea
nosotros siempre les pedimos que traten
de buscar la solución a su problema
entonces que no nosotros tratamos de
buscar la solución a nuestro problema si
tenemos acceso limitado al salón de
cómputo por supuesto no todos los chicos
a lo mejor son usuarios de telcel por
supuesto también pero yo creo que todos
podrían entrar a lo mejor en su casa o
en un cibercafé entonces lo que no todos
tienen a lo mejor computadora o internet
en casa pero de alguna manera si
pudiéramos abrirles un poco más el
abanico de las opciones y de las
oportunidades a ellos porque al final de
cuentas es algo en pro de su educación y
de su formación no entonces me parece
muy muy rescatable lo que dices adrián a
has tenido algún reto o alguna
dificultad en tu trabajo con los chicos
dentro del campeonato o dentro de la
aplicación tú que tienes tanta
experiencia utilizándola
en la aplicación en cuando ingresan en
el celular la semana pasada sí me
comentaron que les marcaban las tareas
pero no dejaba que accedieran a ellas
entonces este yo les dije a lo mejor
revisa el internet de tu casa revisa que
esté bien porque pues ahorita aquí en la
ciudad de méxico hemos tenido muchas
lluvias y en algunos lugares a veces y
de repente también se nos corta el
internet y cosas por el estilo pero este
si en algunos celulares tuvimos que no
los dejaba entrar no sé si a lo mejor es
por la saturación en esas horas a lo
mejor entran muchos chicos y están
activos que por eso a otros no les
permite porque creo que ella ya lo hizo
como que como después de dos o tres
horas y ya pudo ingresar sin ningún
problema a la plataforma son algunas de
las cosas que a veces me han reportado
los chicos
ok recuerdan también que hay una sección
de soporte en donde por ejemplo estamos
viendo algunas dudas o comentarios que
salen en el chat como de es que no me
aparecen las actividades vencidas hablan
opuesto las puedes reprogramar o no nos
están comentando bueno que tienen
algunas fallas digamos con la aplicación
si hubiese algo como muy específico que
no viniera en la parte de ayuda hay una
parte de soporte este y una dirección a
la cual ustedes pueden escribir y pueden
reportar sus problemas o sus fallas para
que puedan ser atendidos o sea no lo
dejemos nada más como hijo lenón pues es
que no se pudo y ya no eso sería como a
lo mejor una excusa que algún día algún
alumno nos podría decir no pero pero
vaya todo tiene solución
vamos a ver de los comentarios que
tenemos acá
en el chat
dice marco antonio contreras que lo está
utilizando como un motivador de punto de
calificación excelente así como tú
adrián a
y él está en diabetes 201 de poncitlán
guau tenemos también por ahí tenemos
algunos comentarios de compañeros tuyos
de conalep
[Música]
por una hora se imparte una hora para
cada grupo en el centro de cómputo y
como obediencia entrega en una captura
de pantalla de su avance y se les dan
dos puntos de su calificación del mes
ahora de dos puntos está hasta alto y
claro
d
mis alumnos de conalep están trabajando
la plataforma para reforzar sus
conocimientos y contextualizar sus
aprendizajes muchas gracias
alien leonor por ahí no sé si tenemos
más dudas no me he ido tan tan tan
arriba
experiencias ahorita no dudas en un
punto animarme a preguntar algo o dos
puntos como como la profesora adriana
ver quién se animó a preguntar
de todos nuestros participantes en línea
aprovechen son cinco minutos de fama
que podemos sacar muy buen provecho
ok como cierre adriana flores adriana
lara para quien hay algún consejo que
quisieran darle a un profesor primerizo
digamos yo estoy viendo este webinar me
gustó tengo curiosidad que hago
quien empieza a ver adriana flores no se
desespere la plataforma
es muy dócil o sea es de muy fácil
entendimiento yo creo que es como todo
hay que sentarnos en la computadora 510
minutos pero de verdad tomarnos en serio
el decir quiero aprender a utilizarla no
es como todo cuando estábamos chiquitos
y nos llegó el videojuego por primera
vez pues te sentabas y te equivocabas 20
veces pero ahí estabas intentándolo y le
picaba si le movía sí entonces eso es lo
que hay que hacer no para qué sirve esto
para qué sirve que ello a ver ahora si
le pico aquí si le picó allá y vamos
adquiriendo la experiencia yo creo que
la plataforma es muy fácil o sea las
secciones vienen muy fáciles nada más
hay que dedicarle un poquito de tiempo
para estar ahí sentados esté
investigando le digo además ustedes ya
tienen muchos tutoriales de cómo
trabajar la plataforma y yo creo que más
que nada no desesperarte no es poco a
poco yo ya llevo tres años y todavía de
repente así como que ahí está acaba de
salir nuevo y ya me pongo a investigar
le como
otra vez pero es este pues paso a paso
muchas gracias a adrián eso es
importante
piénsenlo así profes si te compras un
celular nuevo siempre tienes una curva
de aprendizaje porque ya estabas
acostumbrado a cómo tenías tus
aplicaciones en el celular viejito
entonces hablemos con un par de días
batallas entre híjole como entran a
whatsapp donde pongo está la aplicación
ahora y en fin sucede lo mismo invierte
lee un poquito de tiempo en aprender a
usar la herramienta y vas a ver grandes
resultados y te vas a sentir súper
cómodo utilizándola muchas gracias a
adriana flores adrenalina
algún consejo para algún profe primerizo
aventurero aventurero más bien ahí lo
dijiste creo que la palabra es
aventurero atreverse a cambiar
paradigmas de educación de que los
profesores no tenemos el conocimiento
total que podemos utilizar otras
herramientas que nos ayuden a que los
alumnos aprendan y lo voy a poner con
hache intermedia porque es apropiarse de
los conocimientos y que nos ayuden a que
sea diferente tipo de motivación por
supuesto que las calificaciones ya que
estamos en este sistema es un motivante
súper importante para los alumnos y a
nosotros nos ayuda y nos facilita el
trabajo de esta evaluación continua
total y completamente entonces también
estamos rompiendo esquemas de este
proceso de enseñanza-aprendizaje
lo importante es atreverse a hacer cosas
diferentes innovadoras y locas para que
nuestros alumnos sean mejores cada día
excelente adriana muchas gracias voy a
resaltar que tú no eres una maestra de
ni de matemáticas y de ciencias
damos otras materias o tenemos
experiencia en sociales y humanidades no
hay pretexto también de económico
administrativos o informática no hay
pretexto tenemos contenido dentro de
khan academy que podemos utilizar con
nuestros grupos muchas muchas gracias
adriana gracias último el profe estrella
bendito entre las dos mujeres
participantes para quien directamente
desde sonora desde tu perspectiva y en
tu nivel en tu contexto un consejo para
los profes nuevos aventureros hay 22
frases que me gustan mucho que yo creo
que pueden englobar el consejo y la
primera es que la curiosidad vence al
miedo más fácilmente que el valor
entonces yo creo que si ya están están
aquí es para empezar porque sienten esa
curiosidad que necesita necesitan para
ser maestros extraordinarios entonces al
igual que mis dos compañeras
anteriormente yo les recomiendo así
que vayan y le piquen conozcan la
plataforma es increíblemente sencilla y
no se los digo porque sea maestro
informática de verdad es algo muy simple
de utilizar es algo muy intuitivo y la
segunda frase que les quería comentar
que una frase que me fascina en margaret
mead que la utilizó como firmé mis
correos electrónicos de hecho que es lo
más extraordinario del maestro realmente
bueno es que va más allá de los métodos
educativos aceptados entonces
necesitamos pensar fuera de la caja para
para luego para lograr un impacto en el
nivel educativo me decía laura
centrémonos lea superior no podemos
lograr cosas diferentes si seguimos
haciendo lo mismo tenemos
definitivamente las generaciones que
estamos recibiendo requieren de una
manera distinta de pensar requieren que
pensemos
repito fuera en la caja requieren
estrategias innovadoras y requieren que
nosotros también trabajamos en equipo es
muy eso es muy importante yo creo que lo
que tenemos que dejar atrás es
el paradigma de que nosotros vamos a
hacer los proveedores absolutos del
conocimiento a nuestras clases es
perfectamente válido buscar a otros
compañeros buscar los materiales de khan
este aliarnos en academias en veces no
te derecho algo que se motiva en todos
los subsistemas que trabajamos en equipo
y creo que el cambio en el campeonato
pueden ser una buena oportunidad de
tomar buenas ideas que tuvieron otros
académicos en su momento y que generaron
los materiales que están ya disponibles
para que sus estudiantes los exploten me
permite orientar en la participación
ahorita hace unos hace unos minutos
mientras adriana participaba leía los
comentarios que aparecían en la
transmisión de youtube y me encontré con
un comentario de una docente o docente o
profesor o profesora que comenta que
cuando ya empezaron a los resultados los
estudiantes que estaban haciendo las
actividades le pedían que sacara del
grupo a los que no las estaban esté
haciendo creo yo que ese es un momento
ideal es es un momento es momento de
catarsis para aprovechar
didáctica que permita generar empatía a
nuestros estudiantes yo creo que algo
que debe quedar clave aquí es que no se
trata del campeonato se trata de los
campeones
es decir no van a ganar nada está
terminando el campeonato pero si van a
crecer mucho ellos como campeones que
participaron entonces un consejo que yo
le daría no sólo los docentes primerizos
sino a cualquiera es que aprovechen esta
oportunidad para formar mejores seres
humanos independientemente de la ciencia
y los materiales que tengan los
materiales de campo creo que podemos
aprovecharlos pero para ese factor de
formación integral que tanta falta nos
hacen
excelente tienes toda la razón esa parte
de formar seres humanos es súper
importante luego nos olvidamos de que
esos somos todos seres humanos y podemos
fallar y tenemos muchos aciertos pero me
parecen excelentes tu aportación
respecto a cómo controlar o manejar al
grupo y su
ya su desempeño en el campeonato y
motivarlos y enfocarnos en ellos
muchísimas gracias para quien gracias a
todos los que han estado con nosotros en
esta transmisión estuvo un poco
accidentada al principio pero todavía
están a tiempo de participar en el
campeonato
ahí está la dirección campeonato punto
khan academy punto o hereje no es tarde
ya tenemos un mes pero todavía nos
faltan seis semanas
entonces nos faltan más de la mitad por
favor participen regístrese en el
campeonato y recuerden que para poder
participar el campeonato tienen que
tener por lo menos una clase con 10
alumnos entonces yo creo que sí está
bastante lograble si tienen alguna duda
también escribanos por ahí ahí venía el
principio de la presentación el contacto
leonor arroba khan academy punto o
hereje yo soy laura camacho les
agradecemos muchísimo su tiempo tanto a
los nuestros espectadores y aquí a las
adrián asia barack ley y esperamos
coincidir con ustedes muy pronto
gracias por tu situación
están sintonizando en el que participan
horas